the movie begins with an advertisement
of a revolutionary cosmetic product
known as Beauty water Apparently one can
transform their wrinkly and old skin
into a youthful one by just dipping your
body into this water they can also
reshape their skin and turn into a model
then we are introduced to the
protagonist yaji a depressed girl in her
late 20s who believes that everyone in
the world dislikes her yeji was a smart
and talented girl during her childhood
days and she even won a lot of awards
however because she didn't fit the
beauty standards her confidence went
down and ultimately hit rock bottom now
she has become an obese person who has
given up all her Hobbies just to avoid
attention she lives with her old parents
and has no friends to talk with for a
living she works as a junior makeup
artist at an advertisement company
unfortunately even at work she has no
respite the top model of the company Lee
me rule constantly bullies her in front
of everyone yagi is even asked to cover
her face with a mask so that her hideous
face doesn't scare anyone one day as the
entire crew is busy with me Real's
makeup suddenly a good-looking newbie
actor ji Hoon approaches them he is
there to take part in an advertisement
and yagi is immediately drawn to his
personality his Personality yeah right
jihoon greets everyone in the room
including Ag and even compliments her
beautiful and unique eyes however she is
too stunned to reply as no one has ever
greeted or complimented her for an
eternity just then the Arrogant me real
starts hurling objects at yeji ordering
her to get out of her sight yeji is
humiliated and she immediately rushes
outside then she sits on a bench and
starts cursing me real she hates
everything about that self-obsessed
actress including her surgically
modified face her fake smile and most
importantly her arrogance meanwhile the
handsome jihoon joins her and offers her
a napkin to wipe her tears he then
sympathizes with her and agrees that
miriol is a horrible person who only
thinks about herself with his words miji
feels a bit better and and starts
opening up surprisingly jihoon asks her
to do his makeup right then and there
the latter gladly obliges and begins
doing her thing later at the
advertisement shoot the director
approaches yagi and informs her that an
actor has not arrived so she will have
to take his place all she has to do is
eat some food and in return she will be
given a lot of cash acting is sweet yaji
agrees and after the lead actors perform
their roles yeji starts eating like it's
her last day on Earth at night she heads
to a department store with her
hard-earned cash and buys herself a good
treat but unfortunately it is evident
that even the cashier doesn't want to
face her because of her bad looks this
demotivates the AG slightly but not
enough to ruin her good mood when she
reaches home her mother scolds her for
being late but yagi could care less and
she locks herself in a room as usual
then she sits next to her computer and
starts exploring a community Forum where
people have gathered to express their
hatred towards me real yeji seems to be
an active member of this community and
she has a lot of fun reading the hate
comments she even can type some
sentences and starts laughing like a
maniac this shows how much she hates me
real and this is how trolls are born
however her laughter instantly turns
into disbelief when she comes across
some embarrassing pictures of herself
from the earlier shoot some people
comment that she looks like a Monster
who should be locked up inside a cage as
expected this breaks the AG and she
loses it several weeks pass by but she
is still locked up inside a room yaji
has no motivation to work or to continue
living and all she does is eat and sleep
her worried parents request her to come
out but yeji doesn't even talk to them
one night as she is about to sleep she
suddenly receives a text from an
anonymous person the text mentions that
she has won a beauty product for plastic
surgery but yagi who thinks the text is
a scam throws her phone away and goes to
sleep to her surprise the next day she
gets a parcel at her doorstep inside
there are two bottles of beauty water an
address of the sender and a flash drive
containing instructions on how to use it
Beauty water is the same cosmetic
product product that was advertised at
the start of the movie yaji starts
watching the tutorial video where an
obese lady like her is explaining the
procedure one has to pour the beauty
water in a bowl and then dip their face
in it for 20 minutes no more and no less
hold your breath as the tutorial goes on
yaji is left in utter disbelief when the
lady's fatty face starts withering away
she even grabs a knife and remodels her
face what the hell at the end she
transforms into a stunningly beautiful
girl yeji is taken aback by what she
sees but because her entire life has
been a failure she wants to try the
product a few moments later she finally
gets out of her room but now as a
changed person her face has transformed
into that of an Angel but her body Still
Remains the Same this is because there
was only enough Beauty water for her
face now realizing that the product
actually works yaji craves more and
heads to the address that she found in
the parcel after a bit of walking she
reaches a sketchy apartment and goes to
the seventh floor she then reveals her
name to the CCTV camera and after a
while the door opens it inside she meets
the same lady who is advertising the
beauty water product her name is Gina
and she is the perfect woman when it
comes to appearance yeji is stunned by
her beauty and requests that she be
transformed in the same way but Gina
mentions that everything has a prize she
discloses that about 30 bottles of
beauty water will be required to
transform yagi's entire body and this
will cost about two hundred thousand
dollars adamant on changing herself
yeaji returns home and demands her
parents provide her with the amounts
hearing the number 200k the parents are
taken aback and refuse to comply however
yay G who has now become obsessed with
the product threatens to do something
drastic she also guilt trips them by
stating all the incidents when she had
to suffer alone because her parents were
never there for her in the next scene
miji returns to the sketchy apartment
with a bag and it appears as if she was
able to convince her parents she hands
over the money to Gina and so the
procedure begins she is placed in a
bathtub filled with beauty water and
Gina starts remodeling her body with a
knife when she wakes up she has
transformed into a gorgeous woman from
top to bottom as soon as yeji reaches
home she hugs her astonished mom and
Promises to be a good kid from now on
but the very next second she asks for
five thousand dollars mentioning that
she has to get good clothes to match her
new looks then yeji goes on a shopping
spree and spends way more than she was
supposed to with the days passing by she
starts becoming arrogant and alienates
herself from her parents she also
changes her name to become a completely
different person but in truth she starts
turning into the person she despised the
most Amy Schumer uh me real however yagi
also starts making a name out of herself
using her Newfound appearance she gets
popular on social media and dates a
bunch of Rich guys one day a guy invites
her to an exclusive party and yaji
immediately accepts because she knows
that all the popular and Rich models
party there later she arrives at the
place and stuns everyone with her good
looks the boys are flabbergasted while
the girls are jealous however when yeji
notices some actors on the other side of
the swimming pool and tries to go over a
guy stops her mentioning that only VIPs
are allowed there this makes yeji
realize that simply being pretty won't
get her everything shortly after as she
is exploring the place miriol's director
Han approaches her and offers her his
card he explains that her good looks
will certainly attract a lot of viewers
in the advertisement business and asks
her to give it a try yagi knows Han
personally as she had worked for him as
a makeup artist but still she simply
responds I will think about it at home
while yeji is contemplating whether she
should take the offer she suddenly
realizes that she is gaining weight at
the same time she starts hallucinating
her former self who used to be ugly and
obese alarmed yeji rushes to the
bathroom and decides to take another
bath with beauty water she sets an alarm
for 30 minutes on her phone and then
gets into the bathtub as she closes her
eyes and relaxes she has flashbacks of
the bullying she experienced during her
childhood days unfortunately at the
wrong time her phone battery dies and
the alarm doesn't go off yeah G wakes up
several hours later only to realize that
her body has decomposed to the point
that it's no longer recognizable she
tries getting up and screams for help
but her body can't support her weight
and she falls back inside the bathtub
after a while her mother arrives and
gets terrified to see her in this state
she quickly calls her husband and the
two decide what to do next suddenly the
mother remembers that the beauty water
can also attach flesh to a person but
the problem is that yeji's flesh is
completely melted away and there is no
way to attach it so left with no options
the parents decide to make the ultimate
sacrifice they give away large chunks of
their flesh and attach it to their
daughter's body damn I thought this
movie was just gonna have some
ham-fisted moral about body image but
this is getting dark after a while yeiji
finally wakes up she is still disfigured
and scary but at least she is alive
while the parents are over the moon yeji
is terrified when she sees herself in
the mirror so without wasting any time
she gathers whatever money she still has
and returns to Gina in an attempt to to
regain her lost Beauty unfortunately the
money is just not enough and Gina
refuses to help her this devastates Ag
and she begs to do anything that is
asked of her Gina being an evil person
makes her lick her feet in the next
scene the procedure begins but Gina only
fixes yaegi's face and hands when the
latter wakes up she is confused and
angry at why her body has not been
transformed Gina replies that the money
was only enough to change her face and
hands she also explains that human flesh
is very hard to find so its value is
high however yay ji who still doesn't
want to give up on her dreams begs for
the operation she promises to pay the
money later when she becomes a popular
actress when yeji continues begging Gina
becomes angry and calls her a pig the
word triggers EEG and she starts having
flashbacks of all the bullying she
experienced in her lifetime hence in a
fit of rage she attacks Gina and the two
start tussling it is a fierce fight that
swings both ways but at the end yagi
gains the upper hand and kills Gina now
who's going going to give you weird
knife baths genius following this she
dissolves her body into the beauty water
and later attaches it on her own now
yeji has regained her lost Beauty and
she looks just as stunning as she was a
few hours ago meanwhile a news report
states that several girls in their late
20s have gone missing as of late one of
them is the popular actress miriul who
suddenly left her job and became
contactless taking advantage of this
opportunity yeji starts working in the
same advertisement company and slowly
becomes their best actress now she has
everything good looks Fame and money
something she had always dreamed of
however she still cannot shake off the
guilt of murdering someone one day while
yaji is buying stuff from a convenience
store she stumbles into the handsome
actor from earlier jihoon the two strike
up a conversation and start seeing each
other often yagi is still infatuated by
jihoon because he supported her and made
her feel happy when everyone else
despised her on the other hand the
latter is oblivious that the girl he's
talking to is actually the fat makeup
artist he had met several months ago
days pass by and the two begin dating
yeiji is now living the best version of
her life but yet she is haunted by her
past one day when she is alone she
starts hallucinating and sees that her
body has started wilting terrified she
rushes to her bathroom and prepares to
use the beauty water but for the
procedure to begin she needs some flash
hence she threatens her already weak and
skinny parents for some flesh but when
they start crying yeji has a change of
heart she then looks into the mirror and
it finally Dawns on her that she was
merely hallucinating that night yeji
goes on another date with jihoon and the
two spend some quality time together out
of the blue he takes out a ring and
proposes to her which she happily
accepts after this the two head to
jihoon's apartment to have a dinner yaji
notices his family picture which
strangely doesn't have him in it there
are his parents his beautiful elder
sister and his average looking younger
sister however jihoon explains that his
younger sister is his favorite after a
while he heads to the kitchen to prepare
food while yeji starts touring his house
she stumbles a across his room and
notices a package upon opening it she is
horrified to witness a few bottles of
beauty water yagi investigates the room
further and finds the belongings of all
the girls that have gone missing
recently this finally makes yeji realize
that the Killer is ji-hoon and that he
is after her now terrified she tries
running away but jihoon catches her and
knocks her out when she wakes up she
finds herself inside the bathroom tied
upside down then jihoon steps forward
and reveals himself as the same ugly
daughter in the picture he explains that
all his life he was ridiculed and
chastised for his bad looks so he
changed his gender and transformed into
a man but it was still not enough this
is when he learned about the beauty
water and its magic he started using it
on a regular basis and kidnapped a lot
of girls including miriul to satiate his
flesh demands jihoon further reveals
that the girls were carefully selected
on the basis of their features in fact
the whole advertisement company is set
up to attract beautiful girls and lure
them to him Muriel fell for it and now
yaji has two it turns out the jihu knew
she was the same makeup artist all along
he was amazed by her beautiful eyes the
moment they met and had decided to add
her to his collection the same eyes gave
away yeji's identity saying all of this
jihoon grabs a surgical knife and takes
her eyes out he then carefully joins
them on his legs now yaji has become a
part of him just like several other
girls the movie ends as the cunning
director Han finds another attractive
woman and gives her his visiting card
that was freaking crazy
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching